it is certainly not unheard of for a
young girl to wake up in the middle of
the night looking for a glass of water
it is somewhat more exceptional when
this late night water Run results in
many many deaths unless of course you're
dealing with a very special young girl
scp-053 also known as well the young
girl she possesses the innate ability to
inspire delusions paranoia and
eventually homicidal rage and anyone who
spends too long around her which as you
can probably imagine makes it hard to
live a normal life one night the young
girl woke up to something incredibly
strange the door of versaille typically
tightly sealed was wide open and a
strange flashing red light was shining
in through the hallway the sound of a
distant alarm is what had woken her up
what the young girl didn't know was that
the sight confining her had just
experienced a mass Containment Breach as
a result of a major electrical
malfunction some of the most terrifying
creatures of imaginable were roaming the
halls in search of violence and Carnage
but when the young girl got up and
wandered out of her bedroom she only
wanted a glass of water to quench her
midnight thirst she wandered down a long
plain hallway washed intermittently and
ran by the red flashing emergency lights
she robbed the sleep out of her eyes and
yawned all this strange commotion maybe
she's just having a bad dream but what
seems like a bad dream to her is a bona
fide living nightmare for everyone
around her a few hauls over security
Personnel were being devoured Alive by
scp-682
scp-106 the old man had just dragged a
senior researcher into his pocket
Dimension to do unspeakable things to
him and a group of terrified admin staff
are being lured out by what they think
is a group of mobile task force
operatives but is actually a pack of
hungry
scp-939 imitating their voices still the
young girl persisted in her quest for a
refreshing dress even as security
Personnel began to Fan out through the
building hoping to get control over this
rapidly devolving situation A group of
five armed security officers ran into
the hallway and attempted to intercept
the young girl but the high stress they
were feeling was only accelerated by the
effects of the young girl's anomalous
Powers they started to feel bugs
crawling all over their skin they
started to get the sense that their
fellow security officers weren't even
people but monsters wearing human skin
suits their paranoia soon evolved into a
blistering range each of the men pulled
out their guns and began firing at each
other until only one was left standing
wounded but alive with all the others
dead the object of his rage now became
the young girl herself he understood
then that it was all her doing that
she'd made him do this she was a
monstrous little creature who took
pleasure in twisting the minds of human
beings into terrible forms in reality
the younger girl had no such feelings
her powers were passive she had no
control over them she even suffered from
some kind of strange mental block that
left her completely unaware that her
powers were even taking a fact she was
in a sense completely innocent as the
security officer pointed his gun at the
young girl as she began walking into a
nearby break room he experienced her
secondary anomalous effect anyone who
attempts to hurt her will immediately
die from either a heart attack or a
stroke the security officer suddenly
felt an intense pain sharp and brutal
exploding in his chest he collapsed dead
before he even hit the ground and the
young girl had no idea she couldn't if
she tried in the break room the young
girl found exactly what she was looking
for a classic office water cooler
complete with a stack of plastic cups
perfect she carefully took one of the
cups and pulled down the lever on the
cooler watching her cup fill as the tank
above the cooler bubbled she took a sip
cool Refreshing Spring Water just what
the doctor ordered but the young girl
suddenly looked up shocked to see that
the tank above the water cooler was now
shaking violently as though it was going
to explode what was going on here had
she broken it she stepped back dropping
the rest of her cup of water to the
ground she felt frightened that's when a
crack formed in the plastic tank and the
water began slithering out not dripping
or pouring slithering as though it had
moved with mind and purpose and that's
because in this case it did the young
girl then just drank any water she had
drunk half a cup of water from
scp-054 the water nymph a mysterious
sentient Woman made entirely from water
much like the young girl the water nymph
is often a misunderstood anomaly one
that has received far more harm from the
cruel treatment of the SCP Foundation
than she's ever given to another she's a
naturally curious and compassionate
creature whose trust has been abused so
in the contained breach alarm started to
sound much like the rest of the
foundation staff she had tried to hide
and find cover not wanting to fall into
the crosshairs of a far more dangerous
and hostile anomaly she'd chosen the
water cooler in break room three which
seemed like a genius idea until the
young girl turned up after years of
being experimented on by Foundation
researchers the water nymph wasn't just
about to tolerate more mistreatment
whatever this strange little creature
was who had just consumed some of her
body the water nymph would fight back
and make it regret ever thinking that it
could take advantage of her the young
girl who really had just made an
innocent mistake began to panic and run
as frightening and slithering tendrils
of pure water came slithering after her
as the unfortunate security guard
discovered earlier trying to attack the
young girl was typically a one-way
ticket to a heart attack or fatal
cerebral event but seeing as the water
nymph had neither a heart nor brain she
was invulnerable and the young girl was
terrified she ran out of the room past
the bodies of the men who had killed
each other due to her influence outside
she wasn't even able to notice them she
kept running and the water of the water
nymph came slithering after her the
water nymph had never been the vengeful
type but after the abuse she'd suffered
she learned the value of putting her
liquid foot down she would not tolerate
mistreatment even from a being this
small the young girl kept running
Breathing heavily because of the nature
of her anomalous abilities nobody could
intervene and help her occasionally she
had run into groups of foundation
Personnel trying to fight their way
through the chaos only to be anomalously
affected and become part of the chaos
themselves they became violent deranged
monsters and started attacking each
other punching and biting as they fell
to the ground in a brawling pile the
young girl had to desperately climb over
them as the streak of furious liquid
followed her meanwhile across the
facility The Vicious Psychopathic old
man was hungry for more his mouth
stretched into a wide sadistic grin and
he continued walking further into the
base he would find new victims he would
feel their fear and drink and their
dying screams several mobile task forces
were dispatched from other nearby
containment facilities they'd likely
reach the embattled site within the hour
but how many lives would be lost before
then the death count was already well
into the double digits after all this
running the young girl was getting tired
it was rare that she needed to truly
avoid an escape of threat like this and
as such she wasn't exactly prepared for
such a scenario she found her way into a
broom closet and mocked herself inside
hiding among mops and brooms she tried
to quiet her breathing holding a tiny
hand over her mouth red flashes
continued to occasionally illuminate the
corners of the door she breathed in and
out in and out with something waiting
outside side the young girl gasped as
water started bubbling underneath the
door it started looking around her feet
then rising up from the ground to the
young girl it was astonishing the water
was forming the shape of a woman
standing right in front of her her lower
lip trembled with fear for a moment she
was at a loss for words then she gulped
dryly and began to speak in a soft
little voice I'm so sorry I didn't mean
to hurt you I promise I was just thirsty
the water nymph tilted her head slightly
confused did this tiny child really mean
this was it an honest mistake after all
the Terrible Things had had been done to
her the water nymph had difficulty
trusting humans but as the young girl
started to cry for reasons she couldn't
quite understand the water nymph felt
the urge to comfort her perhaps she
wasn't with the foundation perhaps this
girl was just another prisoner they were
allies not enemies while the water nymph
couldn't speak as a show of solidarity
she began to transform she got smaller
herself becoming a little girl made of
water almost mirroring
scp-053 she raised a hand and waved the
young girl giggled seemingly put at ease
it been a long time since she met a new
friend around here and it seemed like
the water nymph was ready to change that
maybe they could escape this place
together the young girl opened the door
and the two of them ran out together
passing through an adjacent hallway the
young girl ran while the water nymph
slithered formlessly along behind her
they managed to sneak around and avoid
detection from the many anomalies and
Foundation guards duking it out for
Supremacy in the chaotic Halls of the
facility in a sense it provided the
perfect cover for the unlikely Duo to
escape this bizarre situation but they
weren't out of the metaphorical woods
yet first they were cornered by a trio
of paranoid guards all wielding handguns
however the young girl's nightmarish
ambient ability came in handy once more
the three men lost their minds and
started killing each other giving the
young girl and the water nymph more time
to escape and keep moving though they
were about to encounter the deadliest
threat of all the young girl took Point
leading the water nymph down the nearest
hallway when suddenly
scp-106 the old man emerged from the
wall right in front of her he had such
anomalous malice in him that the young
girl's Powers was effectively useless
against him he grinned and approached
her his arms extended ready to Ferry her
off to the nightmare of his pocket
Dimension the young girl had never felt
so afraid until suddenly the water nymph
slithered in between them and she
assumed her full humanoid form once more
forming a wall between the young girl
and the old man this turned out to be
the perfect way to save the young girl's
life
scp-106 has historically found liquid
barriers incredibly confusing and it's
been widely considered to be one of the
few ways to effectively delay the old
man's Rampages seizing the moment the
young girl turned and ran away the water
nymph had just saved her life sadly for
them neither the water nymph nor the
young girl escaped that day the mobile
task forces arrived and took control of
the facility again recontaining the
various anomalies who had escaped but
even if they never saw each other again
the water nymph and the young girl would
forever remember how they helped each
other on that incredibly strange day now
go check out scp-053 young girl and
scp-054 water nymph for more of today's
anomalies